hello everyone pm and Genie here
co-founder and CEO at open Collective
um my presentation today is called the
futurist Collective and some thoughts on
open source sustainability I am thrilled
to be here with you tuning in from
Madrid so here we are the tldr if
there's one thing that I want you all to
take from
um my presentation today is that it's
how we think about sustainability
sustainability refers to the resilience
and the thriving of projects communities
and the individuals that's around them
so we're not talking about financial
sustainability we're not talking just
about money or we're not talking just
about like one aspect we really have a
holistic view we understand
sustainability as the capacity that
communities have of
withstanding change and you know changes
in the environment in the ecosystem in
the in changes for the folks that are in
those projects so that's how we think
about sustainability so really this kind
of comprehensive perspective that we
have
um and so the premise
um that we have that we operate under I
mean something that really guides our
thinking is it has been really well
expressed on in my view by italias from
webpack he said that open sources
software is not free somebody else paid
for it right and again this this has
who's that this somebody else's
maintainers that they pay for it with
their time time away from their families
time
um you know that they are normally that
some paid volunteer time that they're
putting into these projects that
everyone else is taking for free
so what is the issue with this well the
problem is that right that high tech is
a 4.3 trillion um industry that relies
on open source projects that are
cultivated are are taken care
um of by a community of
really underpaid
um if they are ever paid or volunteer
maintainers right and most of our
digital infrastructure relies on you
know the the volunteer work of of folks
um who are in this space
um so whoops here we go
um so what is the really the problem
with
um open source so why is it so hard to
fund open source so if we think about it
like the attributes that open source has
as a public good means that
um it's a non-excludable public good
right like it's not scarce once your
work your software is out there you just
you do not have a way of of gating it
you do not have a way of making it
um available only for some people and
not for others
um and there's really no marginal cost
for another person to use
um the coast the the code sorry there is
like no cost for the user right but as
we can see there's a lot of costs for
the people that are
um creating this technology right again
um and Dominic guitar I don't know if
you if you remember but he did this
um
suffer called event stream that was used
by millions of apps out there and then
someone you know started contributing to
the to event stream and Dominic was
already hadn't already moved on from
that technology because doing something
else he didn't even think that that
technology was the best solution for the
problem that he was trying to solve but
he had like authored this it was there
it was in millions of applications so
there was like this responsibility so
these other contributors started
um you know quite consistently
contributing and then one day he's like
hey if you're not you're not taking care
of this anymore like do you want to give
me the you know keys to the castle and
Dominic is like sure why not like you
know I'm not using it anymore and then
that other
um
um that other contributor used event
stream to inject like a malware
um that was designed to still Bitcoin
um from certain applications right and
so in the middle of all the aftermath of
this drama Dominic said like a modulus
like a piece of digital property a right
that can be transferred but you do not
get any benefit owning it
um you can't sell it you can't rent it
but you still retain the responsibility
right so here I think that in this is
where it lies really the biggest issues
that we have with
um
funding open source that is this
community imbalances that are at the
core of the open source ecosystem on the
one hand we have this
um reality where posting an issue has
zero cost
for
um the the the person posting an issue
hey can you fix this or how does this
work or are you going to be doing any
breaking changes coming up or why is
this thing not working and those are the
nicest ones right normally it's like a
different language vernacular language
um
companies are hooked on open source
right like of course why wouldn't you
when we started open Collective we
obviously used open source like granted
we're a company that is has dedicated
itself to solving this particular
problem but even before that when we
were building a platform like anyone
else who's building Tech you use
everything that is available right
um and so the cost of starting a company
has decreased enormously from uh thanks
to open source and companies have no
interest in obviously going back
um and so what this means is that you
have increasingly more and more people
that are extracting value from a repo
and then those that are maintaining it
right so you have this imbalance between
like the the users that are just you
know extracting value from the artifact
of some creators and those creators are
maintaining that for for free basically
and so you shared your code but you do
not share the responsibility now I'm not
I'm not saying that open source
maintainers do not get anything from
doing open source that is not what I'm
saying I mean obviously there is like a
whole incentive system here that is
operating you get to work on both things
you get to learn you get to try stuff
um you build a name for yourself you
build a career for yourself right it's
challenging it's interesting
um you you meet people you network
um so
it's your personal brand so I I am not
saying that I'm just saying that it's
easy to start a project and do all of
that but then maintaining that project
it's really hard right and leaving that
project is really hard and that's where
once you have a popular project that is
you know spread around
um the whole economy pretty much then
you have like a sensor and a level of
responsibility that is quite daunting
um and so
what we need to think about I think is
what we at open Collective are trying to
to to think if you think about like my
tldr right how we think about it
sustainability in this kind of quite
holistic way then the solution
um to making decentralized Community
sustainable also needs to be
comprehensive it needs to be holistic it
it needs to have like it needs to
address all of these different
components so
we need to figure out ways of paying
maintainers in a way that is comparable
to what a corporation does right like
the the goal of the open source
Collective which is the non-profit that
we created to support the whole open
source ecosystem really our goal is to
make working for open source as
interesting as financially rewarding as
working for a corporation because then
you know then is when you're where when
you're talking in at the same level
right
um and then the second thing has to do
in my mind with how you can make your
communities your your project
sustainable has to do with diversifying
the skill sets that people have in your
project if you only have you know just
people with a very similar skills that
you might have quite a deep
um or very
um
um Elegance or you know software
resolution or it's gonna be technically
um very very good but if you if you
really if your goal is to to sustain a
community of people working online you
need to think about how you're
diversifying the skill sets that you
bring right and so folks who are able to
onboard
other people folks who are able to work
on
um addressing kind of gardening the
community organizing the events making
sure that things inside of the comments
or the GitHub issues are civil that give
have issues or or not just GitHub but
like whatever you use
um issues got triaged and they get
properly prioritized the documentation
gets um you know the tension that it
deserves Etc
um and again it's all about resilience
diversifying the skill sets diversifying
your revenue streams it's gonna make
your community more resilient it's going
to be able to if you just depend on one
Revenue stream if you just depend on say
for example a project
that only has one company putting money
into that project you know you might
have you know a good
Financial standing but if that Revenue
stream gets compromised like it's going
to be very difficult for you and this is
not just in open source it happens
everywhere right obviously but think
about this when you when you're thinking
and again invest heavily in community in
community
um resilience right so onboarding blogs
the type of things that wants to make um
people come to your community now okay
so Financial sustainability is obviously
like one key aspect here right
um
we need to get people paid for the work
they do right and we have like a really
big pain point that um it's quite
obvious by now that in the open source
World formal contracts and partnership
agreements don't happen in the way they
do in the business world right it's why
because open source projects in General
open source communities let me say are
not legal entities and we live in a
world that where corporations speak to
corporations in a scarcity-driven
economy
um that assumes that everyone has a
legal entity and if you're just a bunch
of people doing you know great
technology distributed around the world
using you know
um a platform like gitlab GitHub
feedback whatever it is then companies
do not understand what you are you in
our like lingo you are a circle in a
world that is made for triangles
and so
um that like clashes right and I love
this um
tweet from Swift and security I am
convinced that many developers have no
free kind idea how business actually
works and what operations and
departments have to go through to make
things happen like enrolling a new
vendor is more than difficulty more than
difficult is demoralizing it eats Souls
if you make it easy you are a God so and
I mean it's it's funny I get it but also
I don't think developers should you know
kind of be so worried about about this
not that you shouldn't be worried but
like really it's not in your skill set
which is going back to kind of bringing
diverse skill sets into this like you
are you know super busy doing your job
doing your your your project trying to
hold your community together like
enrolling like a vendor system with sap
for example
I don't know what to say it's like the
worst and so that's how that's why we
created kind of open Collective because
we wanted to create this digital
interface between the projects and then
the host organizations and then you know
the governments like that's what we do
we created this way of helping projects
talk to companies without having to
become a company themselves right so
open Collective essentially what it does
is a platform that allows open source
projects
to receive money but the open open
Collective is a constellation of the
platform that is transparent where you
you can see how the money is being spent
where the money is going right it allows
you to have recurring donations but like
it's it's it's the platform plus like
this network of host organizations
around the world that receive the money
so the host organizations that we call
them fiscal hosts are the ones who talk
to companies talk to reportings so the
open source Collective is a full-blown
501c6 Incorporated in California and we
can talk to any company any foundation
out there the same with the open
Collective foundation and the same like
for example Ruby together right which we
didn't create but they can use the open
Collective platform to receive funding
for their projects so kind of that's one
part of obviously of the of the solution
and yes we will go through your sponsors
vendors setup process for you that I kid
you know it looks like that sometimes so
here we are
um so right now we have
3343 open source projects um we've
um you know we've facilitated
um 30 million in project
um directed
um funding and I I just want to kind of
emphasize this idea of project directed
funding for me this is super important
we do not get involved in
um how the projects spend the funding I
mean it's transparent we get involved in
the compliance obviously but we do not
get involved in how they decide the
money should be spent if you want to
spend it
um equally
um you know if you want to distribute it
equally in um across all maintainers
that's fine if you want to spend it just
on
um community and stuff like organizing
events or paying someone to a technical
writer for your your dogs that's also
fine like we we don't get involved like
the money is from the projects we're
like interfacing we're just enabling you
to hold it right that for us is
um very very important
um and uh wow that looks very big I'm
not sure if it looks that big for you
but anyway like the transparent aspect
of it is um key for us like we created
um
these fund with Samsung next that
distributed like a 680 000 and it was in
full transparency right and it was
really easy for them because they just
sent us one check for this money then we
turn it around and then we we
distributed ourselves to all of these
projects so really it's about making it
easy for companies to give funding to
projects but it's also about
compensating right so it's about
collaborating and it's about
compensating so
um in the past 12 months we've spent 23
million dollars in payments to
maintainers right that's a lot of money
that we paid out
um again it's all about trying to get
maintainers
um and Community
um
um volunteers and and community members
in general being compensated for the
amazing work that they do
so why is Samsung or any other company
giving money to open source right what
are the incentives for corporate funding
um so the and then I'll I'll share some
examples um from this so the first is
naming the community as a good corporate
citizen right like if you wanna
um you know you're using a project
you're using software that you didn't
create
um if you are a good citizen and you
want to be perceived and known as you
should as a good corporate citizen these
kind of supporting open source projects
and investing in open source projects is
there is is um you know gives you that
kind of name and standing in the
community
um some companies invest in open source
projects because they get early access
to information like breaking changes for
example they get some strategic
influence in the roadmap now I think
there's a whole
thing here that we need to discuss about
governance also I mean again
sustainability has to do with like this
at least holistic perception and as a
holistic understanding and so when we
have an influence in the roadmap and we
have
um a lot of corporate funding think
about your different revenue streams
think about the governance think about
the transparency of that corporate
funding right like open Collective I
think makes it easier because you know
how much each company has given to each
project but it's not just about
transparency it's also about how you
decide to communicate this to your
community and what kind of access you
give them there's different projects
that do different things like you know
you can give them voting rights on
prioritization or or whatever but but
really think about kind of corporate
funding also not just in in dollars but
also in terms of like the governance of
your project access to maintainers time
and knowledge like when some when open
source if if you think about what I said
before about it being a public good that
you cannot restrict access to
um the one thing that you can restrict
access to is a time and knowledge right
maintainers time and knowledge it's
higher you know hiring is a competitive
advantage in hiring helps with retention
we know that we've heard this over and
over and over again from companies
um obviously increases the open source
stack health and because it's the you
know right thing to do
essentially sorry but if you're taking
something for free you need to give
something back
um so some examples of how we've seen
this playing over the years like we
we've been doing this for six years now
well coming up to seven actually
um so
Patrick from Trivago he says you know we
we noticed this effect that we didn't
expect like all the public visibility
that they they received from like
supporting webpack being very really
very early on was that they they became
one of the most interesting companies to
work for us a JavaScript developer like
they were having folks
um applying for jobs at Trivago saying
that they knew um how much they invested
in open source
um
um hear from Henry from Babel major
sponsors can access dedicated support
which is really worthwhile so it's far
better to communicate directly with them
versus posting GitHub or Twitter and
waiting for someone to see it
um Michael uh Mike sharov from Adobe he
said this from
webpack as well and Babel and giving
money to webpack meant access to Sean
larking this was you know a couple of
years ago an invaluable bundle of
optimization insights right think about
access to information giving money to
Bubble via employing so different models
here but then
um Henry left bubble and Bubbles still
supported
um
um and sorry left Adobe and Adobe still
supported bubble through open Collective
and they think about this is this is key
they weren't donations this these were
like Investments right
um and so what can you kind of do with
with this um funding or how can you help
um your community get these kind of
corporate funding bunties is a really
good way of doing it like Jay hipster
has like an amazing experience with this
I really encourage you to reach out to
them
um how they help
um critical issues to be solved quicker
if you are like a gold sponsor you can
you can create bug bunties so it creates
this kind of ecosystem and economic
incentives
um
Universal viewer again if you the
another model here for you for you to
think about
um you get a Steering group seat right
having a Steering group is really I
think it's a really interesting
proposition because again when you think
about
um companies having corporate or having
giving you corporate funding and having
access to kind of you know your roadmap
and and having being able to to have
pressure on your roadmap and and
decisions and things like that I think
that having a steering committee makes
that
um more institutionalized and so it
helps it helps it will help you as
maintainers to kind of put some
boundaries in place and of course open
source Collective is more than happy to
chat about any of these things
um whenever you want
um but I think that you cannot just
throw corporate money at the problem you
need to think about infrastructure to
support the community as well as the
visual members of that Community right
again going back to the gldr so we've
been working on some like super
interesting ecosystem initiatives the
first one that you um probably many of
you already know it's sustained where we
created this one day conversation
um about sustaining open source we did
several of these events around the world
and really it's like getting 100 people
in a room practitioners
sustainers corporate fundings
foundations kind of discussing
um you know what we can do about open
source sustainability creating like a
common taxonomy about what open source
sustainability means creating those kind
of you know offers and needs moments Etc
so sustain is like this is how we hold
this space
um first responder was an initiative we
did
um on covid-19 hit like a lot of Open
Source communities like their events
were canceled and
um so they lost a lot of Revenue coming
from sponsorships think about again
diversifying revenue streams right
obviously this is like hopefully a once
in a lifetime
um event but if you have if all your
money is coming from you know your
conference and sponsorships then if you
know something like this happened and
what do you do so we we very quickly
kind of pulled together like some
interesting funding to support a lot of
Open Source projects that suddenly like
realized that they were lost losing all
their funding we have this integration
with GitHub sponsors you know it's not
about competing it's about collaborating
right so if you have
um if you want to receive corporate
funding via GitHub sponsors we can
create a collective for you we're
integrating with them so you know the
money goes straight from GitHub to the
open source Collective to your
Collective you know once a month we just
put the sponsorships there
and we also created
um Democratic funding like so funding um
um open source um this is it was an
effort to
um do community signaling of what
projects and they you know they wanted
to support we use quadratic funding you
can read more about this initiative I'm
very excited about this like we we just
did the One Pilot but like in
collaboration with Bitcoin and and
sustain but I think we you know I think
we might bring this back because it was
it was a very interesting
um experiment
um we created these two funds to support
um you know the the open source
developers supporting Ukraine so a lot
of collective open source projects that
have collectives they pulled money
together from their Collective to
support uh Ukraine so it was really easy
from for them because we you know we
were we're all under the open source
Collective umbrella so we created this
fund to support Ukraine and then
um when the United States left
Afghanistan a couple of Open Source
contributors were stuck there their
family they couldn't live and so we
again open source collect open source
contributors just pull money together
and we helped
um two open source developers and their
families like Escape Afghanistan so
ah and this one is really important we
offer workshops and coaching for
Community leaders like with with
um sumana and change set so again and
this is free it's about thinking about
your project as a community
um okay I'm gonna wrap up soon a word on
things that are not money but they also
matter okay
so pay attention
please pay attention here democratizing
is not just about opening access it's
about Open Access and shared and
participatory governance so when you're
thinking about your code when you're
thinking about your community it's not
just my goal is there is you know you
can access it it's really about creating
communities that have shared and
participatory governance
um and and do not sleep on culture this
is key if culture and the humanity of
what we're doing the fact that we are
individuals we're humans that we are
sharing we are collaborating we're
growing together
um if that gets away from you there's
like no money going to save your
community it's just there's no money
that is going to save it right there's
no enough corporate funding that is
Gonna Save it so do not sleep on culture
and Democratic culture is Upstream of
democratic institutions right so this is
key if we want to create open Democratic
um communities we need to think first of
open Democratic um culture now open
Collective we've grown
um from open source we are now funding a
variety of public goods common
Grassroots communities and social and
political movements as well and so in
fact in the solidarity economy climate
Justice Global movements and civic
participation so it's really an
invitation for you to kind of not just
think about open source but also how
open source kind of seeps into or has
these um these these networks and it's
as linked to this all of these other
communities that you know we're creating
these Bridges between com the mutual and
Aid groups and and Tech and climate
Justice and digital rights so it's it's
about like all of these intersections
that's how we are thinking like we're we
keep growing into this
um holistic View
with dispersed 65 million dollars into
the hands of communities and we
currently have 15 000 communities on the
platform
um
and again like open Collective and
what's the the future for us as many of
you know open Collective we have the
non-profits but open Collective Inc in
itself it's a company that has
um VC funding has investors and so you
know we're always thinking about and for
me this is really something that I think
a lot about a lot how can we
um how can we are I think that what
we're building here is infrastructure
for the commons and I'm obsessed about
how we can get the comments to own open
Collective right so we we think that the
people closest to the pain has to be the
closest to the solution so the future
for open Collective is an exit to
community right how we can really have
the community owning
um open Collective Inc and so we are
thinking about how we can structure a
trust that is going to start buying the
shares of open Collective into the trust
and it's going to have Community
governance and ownership and learning
the future hopefully like revenue and
sharing
right so that is the future of open
Collective and this for me this is what
I'm most excited about today
um it's about really having open
Collective Inc owned by the community
that it's serving so that's it folks
that's it from me
um I'm here be at opencollective.com at
pmng on Twitter yes we're still there in
spite of Elon but I don't know where
else to go I mean I mean in obviously in
the third verse but I'm still on Twitter
so
um yeah come find me let's talk have a
good one and thank you very much for
having me bye